lo primero es que la pandemia del cobi
19 no ha terminado lo segundo es que
existe todavía la posibilidad muy alta
de que nuevas variantes de kobe 19
aparezcan y la tercera es que no habría
una evidencia científica lo
suficientemente importante para
respaldar estas medidas así lo ha dicho
hace pocos minutos en el parlamento del
jefe de la oposición del partido
laborista que está arma también los
nacionalistas escoceses han dicho que el
primer ministro está adelantando
levantar todas estas medidas del que
contra el kobe 19 para salvar su propio
pellejo por meses y meses de escándalo
por lo que se conoce como el partido el
mensaje del primer ministro ha sido
claro esta tarde hay que aprender a
vivir con kobe 19 por ello a partir de
este jueves 24 ya no será necesario
hacerse ni test y tampoco si se es
positivo tendrán las personas que
aislarse ni quienes tengan contactos
cercanos otra medida que ha sido bien
polémica y muy criticada ha sido que a
partir del primero de
los el lateral flow test los test de
antígenos ya no serán gratis ni
disponibles para toda la población
porque antes una de las ventajas aquí en
el reino unido que permitía reportar y
tratar de controlar lo más posible este
comité si no era justamente eso la el
testeo masivo de la población